hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the third leg of the fide grand prix
uh currently being played in berlin it's
hikaru nakamura vs wesley so the first
two classical games ended in a draw and
now we have the two rapid games and uh
we're gonna discuss what happened in
both of them but we are going to show
the first rapid game in length as i um i
thought you guys would enjoy this one a
lot more but we are also going to show a
tiny bit of the second game
as it's very important for what actually
happened in these two games so now
hikaru has the white game in this one
and he opens with e4 uh so this is now
rapid chess and not classical and
players have a lot less time which means
that the lines will get much much
sharper so here we have e5 and the
immediate knight to c3 so hikaru goes
for the vienna game not something you
see very often for example in classical
chess so knight to f6 uh bishop to c4 we
have bishop to c5 and now d3 uh it's
also popular instead of going bishop to
c4 just to go for f4 right away uh but
it's maybe considered a bit uh
riskier and it it is the the absolute
main line so maybe hikaru thinks that
wesley knows that one uh a bit more so
here c6 also preparing the strike in the
center also uh a5 b5 is the plan at some
point you want to start attacking that
light square bishop queen to e2 and now
wesley castles we have knights to f3 and
now uh here where there are there are a
couple moves that were played here but
b5
uh going for this idea right away is a
new move so already as of move six we
have a completely new game ahikaru goes
back bishop to b3 and now d6 defending
the e5 pawn as the knight was attacking
it we have castles by hikaru and now
knight beat the d7 uh wesley continues
development with bishop to g5 and now
pawn to a5 now wesley's threatening a4
as the bishop on b3 will be trapped so
a4 by hikaru making the a2 square
available for the for the bishop and now
b4 chasing away the knight knights to d1
and now h6 so wesley
really enjoying his position uh making
uh hikaru with his uh pieces and very
passive squares bishop the e3 and now
just rook to e8 uh
uh adding more defense to the e5 pawn so
at some point the d5 might also be uh
played so c3 by hikaru and now wesley
plays bishop to a6 and this is uh this
is a great move by wesley he's saying
okay yes you tried to grab the center
you're trying to get d for him but now
you're never getting d4 in and it's a
very very hard to
parry this bishop to a6 idea if you just
play c4 it already looks very clunky now
you just
closed the position and you have a
backwards d3 pawn so at some point it's
only black who can bust open the
position but
black could also do it right now here d5
and white is actually without a good
move to give you one example let's say
he captures on b5 c captures and c
captures on d5 and c captures e4 and
that's pretty much it for white there's
really no way you can play this the
knight is attacked if you move the
knight we're gonna capture on d3 so the
knight could defend the pawn here but
still we just capture and after knight
captures knight e5 we just pile up on
this knight and now okay you could
defend it one more time but now queen
captures and now
uh we attacked the knight three times
also the knight still cannot move the
queen and two would hit an e2 would hang
and after something like bishop captures
on c5 we just go after the knight on d3
open up a discovery on the queen let's
say bishop back to e3 you say all right
maybe i can survive this but now knight
back to e5 attacks the queen attacks the
rook and you're either getting uh
well losing a lot of material here or if
you try to save material let's say you
play something like queen to d2 you
offer a queen trade even knight to f3
check is an option now you have to
capture otherwise you're gonna lose the
queen this way and after g captures
queen captures uh this is now dead lost
for white bishop b7 and it's uh
that's basically a game
uh so after this bishop to a6 idea
queen to c2 by hikaru getting the queen
out of this diagonal and now we have b
captures on c3 here d5 can also be
played but we have to stress out that
this is a rapid time format players do
not have all that much time to consider
moves so b captures and c three b
captures and now rook to b8 already
having some ideas of maybe bishop
captures on d3 followed by rook captures
here or even rook capture some b3
followed by bishop captures on d3 so
rook to e1 by hikaru finally getting
that uh rook out of this diagonal and
now wesley goes for uh the pawn to d5 uh
executing this central pawn thrust with
bishop back to a2 and now bishop
captures an e3 knight captures an e3 and
now knight to c5 so really putting
pressure on hikaru's position uh rook e
to d1 guarding the d3 pawn and now d
captures on e4 we have the captures on
e4 attacking the queen here but now
bishop to d3 uh excellently placing this
bishop here also the queen doesn't
really have all that many squares you
have to play something so queen to c1
and now we have queen to b6
so what can hikaru play here he tries
knight to d2 trying to get the knight
over the c4 now queen to a7 uh we have
knight to d to c4 and not knight f
captures on e4 there was no way to uh to
save guard e for pawn f3 by hikaru and
now knight to f6 we have knight to d6
that's a very active square for the
knight but now wesley plays a rook to f8
rook the e7 would be a bit stronger but
again it's rapid time format rook to f8
we have king to h1 unpinning from this
long uh whoops uh unpainting from this
long diagonal uh and then now comes
bishop to e2 and here uh
this really allows hikaru to get back
into the game here a move like a rook
beat the d8 would have been uh much
better followed by something like e4 but
okay after bishop to e2 he carol now
goes rook to d2 attacks wesley's bishop
bishop back to a6 and now knight e to f5
and here wesley goes knight b3 attacks
the bishop attacks the rook attacks the
queen so the knight has to be captured
we have bishop captures rook captures
but the problem for wesley is now that
the game is completely winning for
hikaru so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this idea while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this wild
attack and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is knight
captures on g7 this is what wins the
game for hikaru he did not play this but
uh he played something very similar so
here you either capture or black is just
in a terrible position so you have to
capture the knight now comes knight to
f5 check king to g8 and now queen to e1
going uh after the g file if you try
something like rook to d6 right away it
seems like this is winning queen's
attacks this uh the knight is attacked
by the rook the problem is there's
knight h7 and now after queen captures
an h6 let's say we play f6 and the
knight and rogue guard on f6 and you're
not getting checkmated because the queen
covers this square so although this
looks incredibly strong it would
actually be the wrong idea queen to e1
is the way to go and now after the king
moves uh now we play rook to d6 attack
the knight here and there's no way uh to
defend this whatever you play you're
gonna lose if you try defending it with
king to g6 we simply play queen to h4 we
give up the knight and that's it and you
don't you really don't have any options
here if you capture just through
captures and f6 checkmate so there are a
couple of uh very strong lines here uh
but going for queen to e1 is is uh uh
going for knight captures and g7 is
absolutely crucial here hikaru tried
queen to e1 first it's also the correct
idea yeah although not as forcing so
he's preparing knight captures on g7 but
now wesley plays king to h7 uh we have
knight captures and g7 uh you could also
try just queen to g3 now going after
this first but okay he goes after knight
captures on g7 king captures and now
queen captures an e5 and here again
hikaru was winning but you have to find
knight to f5 check
that's the problem and now okay once the
queen gets into the game of course you
know that you're winning this uh but
after king to g6 it's also important to
spot rook to d6 and now after king
captures an f5 queen to h4 and the black
king is getting checkmated uh even uh if
queen to e7 now trying to guard the
knight we just play rook captures on f6
queen captures and queen to g4 we always
know that if these two squares are taken
away from the king then a queen uh
checking the king from a diagonal will
be checkmate so after king captures on
g7 he car played queen captures on e5
now comes queen to b8 uh if the knight
now moves we don't want to allow a move
like knight to e4 going after this
knight so h for by hikaru rook to b1
with check forcing a trade of rooks rook
captures queen captures again with check
king to h2 now comes queen back to g6
and now the black queen will help out
with the defense of the black king
knight to f5 with king h7 and now rook
to d6 piling up on the f6 square
rook the g8 threatening checkmate and
now comes g3 another finesse
that you have to spot uh even though you
don't have all that much time on the
clock if you play g4 which seems like
move you really want to play then wesley
has this freeing queen capture sanji for
that's the problem the queen and king
are just uh in the line of fire for for
the knights to deliver a fork after f
captures knight captures with check king
and queen are forked and after you move
the king now not uh and not
not this because then you get checkmated
rook captures on h6
will be checkmate the knight covers the
g7 square but you actually have to go
for the perpetual here knight f2 cher
king here and now whatever you play
we're just gonna continue checking the
white king and it's a perpetual so g4
would actually be a forced perpetual so
hikaru plays g3 he still wants to push
this rook to e8 attacking the white
queen now comes queen captures on f6 uh
rook the e2 with check now uh king h3
and now bishop the c8 wesley really
found a brilliancy here to defend this
position because if you don't find this
bishop the c8 resource you are not
surviving this uh and now of course if
the queens
are traded off captures captures uh
hikar would also lose the knight here uh
so wesley would win the game so hikaru
now has to play g4 and now we play
bishop captures on f5 and without this
knight here you are not breaking through
uh wesley's defenses so here queen
captures an f5 queen captures an f5 g
captures on f5 and now we have this end
game
where uh hikaru is up a pawn but it's a
double death pawn it's very hard to
push something like this so in a rook's
end game so here c5 we've rooked a6
going after the pawn he car does the
same uh alright wesley does the same
goes after hikar respawns king to g4 now
rook captures on c3 creating a past c
pawn rook captures on a5 creating a past
a pawn rook the c for which a king g3
now rook to b4 uh trying to get uh uh
hikaru to capture this pawn so wesley
can capture this pawn but now we have h5
c4 starting to push the pass pawn and
now rook to a7 going after this pawn so
king g7 defending now comes rook to a6
preparing pawn to f6 so c3 and now f6
with check now hikaru is covering both
of these squares king h7 now comes rook
to c6 attacking the pawn here so rook
captures on a4 uh and now rook to c7
rook captures on c3 is also fine but you
might as well threaten to capture this
pawn first and you can always capture on
c3 uh so king the g8 now comes rook to
c8 with check these uh squares are not
available to the king so he has to go to
h7 so king h7 he call repeats rook to c7
king g8 rook to c8 king h7 and he was in
this position on rule 56 that the
players agreed to a draw uh or rather it
was a draw by threefold repetition so
uh from the start of the game the uh
possession really looked like wesley was
going to win the game uh then uh he made
that bishop to e2 move which wasn't um
the way to go and then hikaru had a
position where he could have played for
the win with that knight captures on g7
id or knight f5 idea but again this is
rapid it's impossible to spot everything
so the first game ends in a draw and
then the second game uh this is the
second game and we're just going to show
you what happened in this position now
wesley had the white pieces and he carl
played this c6 move and this is not a
big problem for him
because well by playing this he
basically uh
lost control over the d6 square and that
means that
well wesley can just break through so
wesley played bishop captures on e5 here
uh going uh
for that d6 square and now if you
capture with the rook then knight to d7
check forks everything here so that's a
game for white so of course uh e ca d
captures and e5 was have to
was played and then just d6 so by
playing c6 you lost control of this with
this square and this is uh what made it
possible for wesley to play this now you
either give up the rook or you move the
rook away from the seventh rank because
these squares are covered by the pawn
this is covered by the knight so the
rook cannot remain here and once the
rook moves anywhere we're just gonna
play knight here uh check the king and
pick up the bishop this is actually what
happened in the game but now wesley was
up a piece and he was able to win this
end game against hikaru of course um as
he is up a piece uh so yeah that's what
happened in the second game uh wesley
won and this is the final position after
rook to f6 czech king g5 he carplay king
g5 and also in this position uh unmove
65
is that hikaru nakamura resigned the
game we even have a nice video of this
moment of the handshake so let's check
that out uh this is when it happens so
you can see hikaru has the king on g5
shakes the hand and there it is
uh brilliant brilliant stuff uh wesley
takes the win uh so after two classical
games uh uh the match was a draw then
the third game of the rap it's really a
wonderful one you've seen what happened
it was really anyone's game
and then wesley just continued playing
on the absolute highest level and he was
able to win the fourth game which means
that wesley is the winner of the third
leg of the
berlin feed a grand prix uh so
unfortunately for him this does not
qualify him for the candidates
tournament as you have to uh play really
really well during uh the two grand prix
that you are playing in and he car
played brilliantly he won the first one
and he reached the the finals of the
second one so hikaru and rapport were
the ones that qualified via the grand
prix and the wesley said that he is
still very young that he is hoping to
qualify uh for maybe the next cycle of
the candidates tournament because of the
one that he did play uh he was uh
inexperienced he was very young and that
he finished second to last so he's
hoping to do much much better on the
next one but yeah uh that's uh the game
and this very short coverage of the
feeder grand prix hope you guys enjoyed
this uh i would like to thank christian
jannot uh matthew chested murmurs gambit
open c smokey duel and openc smokey
dooley for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day